non
ce travail là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui on est allés chez nous
ce soir cette année on va faire un petit
concours de quartier regardez ils sont
la mer s'il est là les chérit tant dans
sa vie on fait la fiche alors comment ça
va bien merci
il y perd 6,7 cela donne un beau sam en
syrie lui aussi les bobos qui commença
dans mes chéris donne toute l'équipe de
top gear est avec nous ce soir les
cherry qui veut faire une course contre
isabelle ne faut pas que tu veux gagner
agathe39 trisha yearwood compris
mais moi je m'arrête
séparés
ça va hélas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
trois deux un match plus avec les routes
c'est pas juste
bon désolé chérie c'est n'importe quoi
allécher
calmez-vous câm tu m'as glisse l abruti
[Musique]